David, the more I see the left get
involved in these cultural issues
like cancer, culture and wackiness, the
more I think the left should just not even
bother to fight those issues. What do you
think? This is a very interesting question.
We see that right now there's a really big divide
between the Democratic and Republican Party in
the sense that the Democratic Party is almost
exclusively about legislation and issues and the
Republican Party is not. And earlier this week,
I argued with Republican strategist Amanda Macchi
about it, who I still don't even know exactly what
point she was trying to make. But needless to say,
her argument is, well, now Republicans can't do
policy because they don't control anything. Well,
but they didn't do any policy during the Trump
era either. As a result, the right is just
fighting cultural issues. They're talking about
council culture. They're talking about control
in a trans sports control of the narrative by the
left ness and all of this different stuff up. I
don't believe that the left should give up those
issues, but I do think that it would be best for
the left to realize that just because an issue is
getting a lot of traction on Twitter and Fox News
doesn't mean it's actually an issue that much
of the Democratic electorate cares about. And
you need to look only at the 20, 20 Democratic
primary to understand that. And I know this is
painful for many in my audience to hear. I wish
it were different, but there were a lot of people,
millions of people on the left who spend a lot of
time on Twitter and Reddit and saw the enthusiasm
for Bernie Sanders at rallies and wrongly believed
that the Bernie wing of the Democratic electorate
was is bigger than it actually is. It doesn't
mean it's insignificant. It doesn't mean it
doesn't matter. It doesn't mean that that it's
not a wing with good ideas. It is. But the 20 20
Democratic primary reminded us when it wasn't even
close. I mean, Joe Biden really won very easily by
millions of votes, even before it was, you know,
everybody bailed and all that all that stuff.
What you see on Reddit and Twitter and on Newsmax
or Fox News, it's not what the bulk of the country
actually cares about. And similarly, for me, it's
not about the left conceding or giving up on the
cultural issues. It's understanding that most
Americans are not focused in on trans sports
wackiness, Dr. Seuss or cancel culture.
They're just not. First of all, tons of
Americans don't even pay attention to news in
the way that you and I do. And of those that do,
we know the issues that are most important.
It's in no particular order. The economy, jobs,
wages, health care, coronavirus pandemic recovery.
Those those are the issues. Those are the primary
issues. So once you understand that and then you
realize that very little of these culture wars
involve actual policymakers in policy positions,
this is an important distinction. Yes. Congressman
Jim Jordan will go on Laura Ingram's show and
talk about the council culture. Laura, you know,
he does that Matt Gates, when he's trying to
distract from, you know, investigations into
child sex trafficking, he will talk about
Cancela culture. Trump talk to I get it.
You see people like, you know, Marjorie Taylor
Green or whatever, try to bring some of this
stuff to the House floor. Jim Jordan says you need
an investigation into Dr. Seuss for the most part.
Very little of this culture war stuff is even
touching real policy making, legislative time
at the state level and at the national level,
it's amplified by conservatives, a few of them,
it's amplified by the Internet, it's
amplified by some right wing media.
So the way I would say it is, Democrats don't
need to just concede a loss on cultural issues.
Democrats don't need to not bother fighting on
cultural issues. Democrats just need to recognize
that the culture war is a distraction
that Republicans have chosen to take on
because they have no policy ideas other
than prevent Democrats from doing anything.
And they have nothing to actually bring
to the table at this point in time.
One last thought on this, eventually, Democrats
tend to be vindicated on most of these cultural
issues. I mean, look at abortion, OK?
It took, what, 40, 50 years. Abortion
being legal in most cases, is more popular
now than at any point since Roe v. Wade. It
took a while, but the culture shifted and
caught up with where the left has been,
gay marriage, most people in the US, including
more than 50 percent of Republicans, now believe
gay marriage should just be legal. It's been legal
since twenty fifteen Democrats. The left have been
fighting for that for much longer. Eventually,
the culture came around. Marijuana approval,
death penalty, not being you get it right.
So another reason not to engage in the way
that the right wants to is that eventually the
country tends to come around. Now, you don't want
to ignore serious issues like death penalty,
marijuana, etc. altogether, because if you do
that, nobody's advocating for your side. But the
council culture thing is different. And I do think
that Democrats should just understand that this
is not a big issue to most Americans, period.